[MUSIC]
So I thought we'd do two
main sets of things.
I want to talk to you about your signature
culture, because I think it is so
interesting to all of us.
And then at some point we'll pivot from
that into talking a little bit more
generally about leadership, leadership
style, and how you approach leadership,
and then we'll leave some time for
questions from the audience and
we'll wrap up at the end.
So, talk to me about some of these
signature pieces of the culture
that I refer to in my opening remarks, the
idea of mayor and village and teammates.
The dress up,
the chanting that I heard backstage.
What's the story behind all of this?
>> Yeah, so we believe we're
a community first and a company second.
And hopefully,
everybody has some communities that
they're a part of In their life.
It could be their family, could be
their book club, could be their church,
could be their sports team,
could be their best friends.
Community basically means that people care
about each other, respect each other and
they care about the organization
that they are apart of.
That they're stewards that care about
what they give on to the next generation.
That's the basic concept of community.
And so we believe in that fervently
that given we spend more than 50% of
our waking hours as an adult at work,
and for some of us,
it's way more than 50%, especially if you
travel, that to concede that in any way
that shouldn't be central to your life
mission, and that you shouldn't be
emotionally engaged with the people
that you work with all that time.
We think it's a grotesque concession
that some people have to make.
And a lot of people don't have to.
And people like the ones in this room are
going to have a spectacularly big impact
on the folks that work for
you through the course of your life.
And so we said, okay we're going to
be a community, act like a community,
let's call it a village.
Let's make it the mayor because that
raises the bar of expected behavior
for us.
And so we take it very seriously when
we make decisions, we consistently use
the metaphor, if your a Mayor of
a village, how would you decide?
Because if you're a mayor of a village,
you care about the economy, but
the economy is the means to an end,
it's not the end.
You want to help the economy so you can
have good schools, good parks, etc.
>> So, I have to say, I mean I alluded to
what happened in the green room, before.
But it is very impressive.
So here you are meeting up with
a bunch of folks from, you know,
the local area, who,
you don't do this every day.
And yet, you were able to
lead them through a series of
cheers which are clearly deeply ingrained.
And done as you can see, by just
looking around the room, with you know,
with a sense of passion and by in.
Which of course is critical to having,
we can talk about culture all we like.
But getting it bought in in that way
deeply through a fortune 500 company.
I mean that's tough.
So could you tell us a little bit about,
how do you go about that?
How do you do that?
>> Well first, teammates stand up.
What the heck.
I got some teammates here.
So.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I knew there were going to be a couple
here, but I didn't know that
there was going to be a bunch.
And so
this is a pleasant surprise right before.
So I will ask them three questions.
Stay standing.
What is this company?
>> You.
>> Whose company is it?
>> Ours.
>> And what can it be?
>> Special.
>> And if we are to build the greatest
health care community the world has ever
seen, let it be like this one for all!
>> All for one.
>> Damn straight!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So
this part wasn't conscious when
we started this adventure.
And it kind of popped up organically.
And what we find is that healthy tribes,
military units, religions, sports teams.
Places that have strong sense of team,
strong sense of community,
they do call and response.
A language means something.
>> Yeah.
>> Rituals mean something.
And so
we said if we're going to be a community,
we should have the attributes of
a healthy religion, tribe, village.
And it turns out call and responses is
what happens naturally in those quarters.
Doesn't happen naturally
in most companies.
>> Right.
>> Because they're sort of
morally sterile.
>> [LAUGH]
No value judgment implied.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] I said sort of.
>> [LAUGH] So it is
pretty amazing to watch, but
how do you know it works?
Obviously, it works in that
you're able to perpetuate it, but
how do you know that you're
distinctive because of it?
How do you know that you're getting
superior results because of it?
>> Yeah, so we're very metric oriented.
And if you're going to be
serious about being a community,
you've got to be objective.
And we certainly, not all of our
neighborhoods are happy neighborhoods, but
our clinical outcomes
are superior to our competition.
The government just came out with a new
rating system, for example only 30% of
the centers in America, in dialysis, which
is one of our two big businesses, can be
ranked at four or five, and the percentage
of our centers that are in those four or
five categories is twice
as high as any competitor.
So it's a crushing example.
In addition we did an acquisition,
about a three billion dollar acquisition,
x years ago.
We did all the analysis, our wages were
the same, our salaries were the same.
We were in all the same
geographies across America.
Their turnover was 40% higher.
So if we were them we would have had to
hire an extra 1,200 people a year compared
to what we had to do given the difference
in retention at the same pay across
America.
And third there's some of the big
consulting firms the Ann's,
the Hewitt's that do standard
questions across big companies.
And our team mate engagement
scores are quite high, and
then I'll give one anecdote.
About five, six years in, a woman came
up to me at a big conference, and said,
they've been hired by a pharmaceutical
company to do focus groups with patients.
And you know they had never worked for
us, they were never going to work for us,
and she said by the third city,
we were playing a game,
because that's when you
have a facilitator,
and then the sponsors are behind a mirror,
looking at the people, and
then the 15 patients answering the
questions, just like they do with cars and
toothpaste and all that, and
by the third city, we played a game that
about 40 minutes in, since they didn't ask
the question of do you know who owns and
operates your dialysis center, until
the very end, about 40 minutes into it,
they would play a game and guess which
patients were the Devita patients.
Because you could tell that
they talked differently.
And this, at this point was across
a thousand different locations,
small locations across America.
That was, for us,
separate from all those hard metrics,
that was perhaps the most special one,
that human beings talked differently.
>> You spoke a little bit
about some acquisitions and
spreading culture through acquisitions and
the one that you referred to is one where
it was really a like business model that
you were taking the culture and too bad.
And of course,
a couple years ago you bought HBC,
which is in a quite different,
related but different business.
So have you tried to take
the same culture there?
Are there limits to the extent to
which you can transfer the culture to?
>> Both the big dialysis company,
when we bought them,
they were horrified at the notion of
being subjected to this weird shit.
Yeah, that they said it looks like a cult.
>> That's a technical term.
>> Yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A term, it's a, I'm just quoting them.
The, that this seems like a cult.
It seems sophomoric.
It seems cheesy.
It seems inappropriate,
cavalier, and both there and
then with this related business
three years ago, they were similarly
worried about being subjected to it,
forced to try to adopt it.
We made very clear in rooms like this,
only not as nice,
we can't afford nice rooms like this.
They make very clear,
please don't use our language, unless or
until it becomes comfortable.
Don't talk about, don't feel like
you have to talk about our values or
some of our concepts for the village.
Don't do any of that, get to know us.
Watch how we behave, watch how we
interact, and then a year downstream,
we'll talk about whether or not we need
to change any of the values or whatever.
And both the first time and
second time, legacy
to be the veterans were appalled that
I would say that we might change them.
But my response was, if you're a village,
you have to represent the current
population, and when you have a lot
of new people, it's a new thing.
And you need to speak for
that new community and
in the case of this related acquisition,
that from a business point of view,
the first two years went very poorly.
Tremendous organizational change,
we took out half the senior executives, so
relatively traumatized organization which
exasperated the fear around
one hell of a village.
You let half the people go and
you're introducing all this change.
And so in the second nationwide meeting
since the time we closed the deal,
once a year we get our top
4,000 leaders or so together,
I went off in a room with the 270 leaders
from that enterprise, 18 months in,
traumatic 18 months, and said, okay,
now we're going to have a debate.
Do you want to go adopt the legacy
DaVita vision, mission and values?
Do you want to keep what you have,
wait another year, keep it forever, or
somewhere in between?
And it was a very intense debate.
About 80 out of that 250 people or
so were physicians.
People from all over America somewhere new
to the enterprise because the acquisitions
had been in post flow,
some of them had been there 25 years.
They went through it, and about
halfway through a woman stood up, and
it was a very intense debate, a woman
stood up, and one thing we didn't have on
the ballot was go all in and
take the vision mission and values.
You can take these two,
these two-thirds or just one or none.
Because we never thought it would go all
in, but this one woman stood up and said,
you know what, it's been a year and
a half since the deal.
We have wonderful people in our company,
health care partners, they have
wonderful people in legacy, DaVita.
They are living the values
that we all agree with,
with far more intentionality and
follow through and
purpose and robustness than we are,
and I want to be one company.
I vote for all in, I think that
should be added to the ballot.
Applause broke out in the room.
We had another hour of debate,
both in small groups and big groups and
at the end of that two and a half hours.
That 260 or so leaders from that
enterprise voted 85% to go all in.
14 of the remaining 15 voted to
go two- thirds of the way in.
Only 1% voted, so they voted for,
embraced the village concept themselves,
much to, I think, to their own surprise.
No one knew what the outcome was going to
be going into that room, and therefore,
there was no one subjected to anything,
and they went out and
told everybody across America that.
I've sort of taken this
stuff more seriously now and
in fact I just voted for it.
>> And, has it taken root?
I'd say the math I use as I
think we're one third teammates,
citizens, maybe more, maybe 33 to 40%.
We're about 30 to 35% in
a just still watching,
observing and whatever number
is left are still negative.
>> So, still on the subject
of exporting the culture,
you've taken DaVita now internationally.
Can you talk a little bit about
some of the challenges, and
taking this kind of corporate
culture to international cultures?
>> This has been very intense.
So first,
when you think about core values,
some people will look at them on a wall
and say, it's motherhood and apple pie.
Who doesn't believe in integrity?
Who doesn't believe in team?
What a dumb, pointless list,
everybody believes in them.
And as a leader the issue is not belief,
it's practice.
So yeah, I believe in all those things.
If you evaluate exactly how I behave
everyday some people would say, hey KT,
I'm not so sure that you're living
that core value that you believe in.
And even harder to create an environment
where everybody practices that
an not violating a core value
does not equal living it.
So if I go a month without telling a lie
that is not living a life of integrity.
Living a life of integrity is when you
tell the truth when it hurts when its
embarrassing when you didn't have to.
If i go a month without blaming
someone for something they didn't do,
I'm not living a code
value of accountability.
Living code value of accountability
is when someone makes a mistake and
no one thinks you had
anything to do with it.
And you realize that you knew
the person wasn't very good about that.
You could have taken
them aside two weeks for
half an hour,
they never would have made the mistake.
And you stand up and take accountability
because you said, you know what,
I could have prevented that,
I know Josh was uncertain or whatever.
And so there's a big difference
between not violating and
living, and
it's contagious how that works.
And so internationally, when we decided
to go, if I was a better CEO we would
have gone international ten years ago, but
I wasn't, so we started four years ago.
And I went to other CEO's from prestigious
business schools like Stanford,
and they all said, you know that weird
stuff you do, leave it at the airport.
>> [LAUGH]
>> because, it's unusual,
even in America, so don't you dare
try to do it in Saudi Arabia,
don't you dare try and
do it in China, etc.
Poland, Portugal, Columbia, India,
all these other places we are.
So I took their advice, and then I was
giving a talk to a bunch of our Indian
teammates x months later as we begin
to grow and it just fell totally flat.
And so I went to the boss after,
I knew him enough where he was
honest to give me that gift.
I said well that really fell flat, and
he said, they've all been on the Internet.
If you go walk around their cubicles,
they've got the DeVita symbols up.
They've got the story of how our
neighborhood has grown within the context.
And now they're feeling like this village
thing, that's just about America and
they're not really citizens,
they're just foreign laborers.
And so I voice-mailed back,
we went full on, and
in doing that,
you find out that it's about human values.
That everyone wants to have a robust
discussion around actual human values and
whether or not they're used in making
day-to-day business decisions or not.
It's not a fairy tale thing, and
we've had uncomfortable moments in some
of the cultures, as we work through.
In particular, for example,
because we won't stand for
some of the gender discrimination that
exists in a lot of other societies,
and that leads to awkwardness.
And then one other moment of awkwardness,
and then I'll stop.
So you're trying to get the right
translations is not always
straight forward.
And so it turns out in one country,
the word that we were using for
fulfillment, basically means masturbation.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, and so
we were saying,
you know fulfillment's very important.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We think everyone should be fulfilled.
You know even we hold our leaders
accountable for fulfillment.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then someone gave the speaker,
it was not me, the gift.
So there are speed bumps.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In the way.
>> And you had metrics to track.
>> Yes, yes, right.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I mean, probably trivia
of your days have been, but when we
teach strategy we talk of course about
alignment between organization,
including culture and strategy.
But then we also talk about alignment
between that and the excellent
environment that you find yourself in,
industry and so on, so the question
really is How general do you think the
applicability of this kind of culture is?
Is this something that works
in mission driven healthcare,
mission driven kinds of industries?
Is this something that you think
could applied more broadly?
What are the limits?
>> This is one where we're quite intense
because a lot of people will kind of go,
oh they're nice little
health care service people.
And I'm sure very pleasant to talk to,
but they probably lose
all their football games.
And we over the last 16
years are in the top 5%
of New York Stock Exchange performers.
We outperform our competition
in clinical outcomes.
And a lot of our teammates
have gone on to be COs and
COOs of lots of other companies.
So we don't think there's any tension
between achieving capitalistic and
market based net worth ambitions, and
creating a healthy and
distinctive community for people to work.
We think there's no tension between those.
In fact, we think they're in some ways
cohabitate very positively and so
if I was running an enterprise
with 3,000 Taco Bells,
not medical clinics or
a coal mine, or any,
it is all about creating
a differentially healthy environment for
people to work, particularly the people
that don't have the career options and
income flexibility that most
of us in this room have.
That, that applies to any business.
That we, a healthy workplace
is a gift to that mommy or
that daddy that they will take home.
It is a gift that they will savor at work.
And it's about basic ways in which
humans behave with one another.
So we believe passionately,
that it's transferable everywhere.
That's not to say that there aren't
differences in how one would implement,
how it would manifest itself
in a Goldman Sachs, or
a Bain company,
versus the other organizations
that the demographics of
the citizenship does affect it.
But the basic principles have to do
with how we behave with one another.
And whether or not it's consistent with
the values that we allege to hold dear.
>> And so I'd like to start to
transition to leadership and
keep one foot in culture and
put one foot in leadership.
So some of the things that
we're talking about village,
mayor, community, sounds soft.
They sound soft.
They sound a little bit squishy.
Very GSPS actually.
>> I wasn't going to say it.
>> We're also heavily into costumes,
which you call uniforms.
So see a parallel there as well.
But at the end of the day,
you're the CEO of a Fortune 500 company.
And that's a tough role.
It requires tough decision making.
It requires holding people accountable.
You know, that doesn't sound so
soft and squishy actually.
So I'm just wondering how much of this
translates into your day to day job?
How do you think about that?
>> And Elizabeth at some
point the video is ready.
We can play it.
Okay, didn't okay.
It's where the metaphor comes in so handy,
if your the mayor of a village,
everyone knows the village has to
have a healthy economy in order to create
jobs for people to have, everybody knows
you gotta pay taxes that support
the school system and the police so.
But there is serious issues
of who to pay how much tax.
How transparent is the deployment
of the tax funds that are raised?
How competent are the organizations
that spend the tax money?
So we think of profits to
the share holder like that.
So we are very open about it, that we
don't get to create the DaVita University
that our people love, with a tremendous
emphasis on personal reflection and
introspection, not just applied stuff.
We don't get to grow and
create career opportunities.
We don't get to grow and create profit
sharing awards unless we are allocated
capital, which is just like a mayor's
gotta collect tax money in order to all
the things the citizens want to exist,
the parks and the summer programs.
And we find that it doesn't matter, we
have 18,000 folks out of our 65,000 that
have not been to college and never will.
They understand the concepts totally
about what real life is like,
if they feel you're honest and
transparent about what reality is,
and are willing to have real debates.
So I've gotten up in front of thousands
of our teammates, and talked about my
compensation, an executive compensation,
with people making $17 dollars an hour.
And they get the right to ask questions,
or send messages.
So first, there's an issue of just
basic straight forward honesty,
and transparency, and explanation
to kind of loop things together in
a way that otherwise doesn't work.
And then second,
when we talk about tough decisions,
we will discuss them in
the context of a metaphor.
Give one example,
we made that big acquisition referred
to while the government was appropriating
any requires to do some divestitures.
And when you do the divestitures,
what the FTC requires, is that
you either divest all of the legacy Davita
centers or all of the new companies'.
You can't pick and choose because
you would cherry pick all the best
market positions and he can't do that,
it's a reasonable federal policy.
Everybody assumed,
I mean everybody assumed,
that I would decide to divest all
centers from the company we were buying.
Some of these folks would've been
in part of this, and I said no.
If the other company that we're buying
has got a group that's on the ascendancy,
that is a clear long-term winner, then we
will divest the legacy DaVita centers.
People were appalled.
You know, this is a violation.
We love the village,
we've been good citizens of the village.
We have excellent clinical outcomes.
And you're going to sell us?
You don't even know who you're going to
sell it to, and we can't even switch and
work because the way the FTC rules work,
you can't take all the employees.
You gotta,
there's a certain hands off period.
In our case, teammates are employees,
they call them employees.
And so, people are livid.
And I got up in a room, a much bigger
room, with 3,000 of our leaders and
explained that job one of a mayor of
a village is to make sure the village is
sustainable for the long term, because
every single one of us talking to them
is going to leave
the village at some time.
Because we get a great job offer,
because we retire, because their
spouse gets transferred, and so
we are all stewards for
the next set of people in these chairs.
And for maintaining an environment
where we can provide superb care for
our patients.
That's job one, and
just like if you're mayor of a village and
you know you've got to put a highway in or
your downtown's going to deteriorate and
you're going to lose
to some other village.
You know you gotta rip down houses to put
in that highway, and some of those people
will have lived in those houses for
25 years, love their neighborhood,
and you're going to rip down their
house to put in a freaking highway.
But that's the right thing.
Either that or
the place goes dead in 30 years.
And got up and explained why I
had decided what I decided, and
about 70% of the people being divested
came up after, most of them crying,
saying that they accepted the logic that
the decision was best for the village, and
I was consistent with my responsibility,
and they were very sad but understood.
So we put it together because life.
>> Yeah
>> Is hard sometimes.
>> And how much of this translates to
decision making with your core team?
You were talking about
the village at large.
But when you bring this back
to core management team,
what are some of the tough
decisions you've made?
Are there times where you've had to go
against the wisdom of the core team and
say You know I am the mayor,
I think this is the right decision.
>> Yeah they've been.
We do a lot of votes compared
to most organizations.
Votes with thousands of people involved,
sometimes hundreds of people involved.
But I always retain the right
to overrule the vote.
I mean it's the discussion that matters.
And the data is very useful for
me and for others but
in the end I have the job I have that
should come with differential insight and
should carry with it
a differentiated experience.
Some people would question that and so
we had one business that I wanted to buy
and the entire team wrote against it.
So I hired Baine and then they came
out and recommended against it.
So, we stopped that project and
I pulled out of the process and
then I went home that weekend.
And I just said,
our alleged vision at that point,
because we were just
Kidney Care at that point,
was to transform Kidney Care in America,
which we're halfway there.
And this was 13 years ago.
And we cannot seriously try to do
that unless we buy this thing,
even though right now it's little and
broken and there's no pro forma
you can do that makes sense.
That we have to change a bunch
of laws to do a lot of things.
And I went back on Monday and
told the team we're going to buy it and
I respect all of the reasons, but it's
not inconsistent with our construct and
then I guess the other part of it was
implicit in the question about core team,
in the I am sensitive to the fact
that there are times that I
behave in ways that are inconsistent
with our mission values.
In particular with my core team,
let me say, bring it back to that.
And that is where one hopes
that you scored enough
points in terms of intentionality,
that people forgive you for
your behavioral
transactional shortcomings.
>> Do they call you on it?
Do they feel comfortable
enough to call you on it?
Do you apologize for it?
How does that go?
>> I'd say that's, I'm a bit curious
what some of the teammates say.
I think we're seriously above average, and
people are going to be
willing to call us on it.
I get scored on the core
values every year,
an independent consultant goes out and
talks to a lot of folks.
My scores are made public to the board and
to the teammates as well
as a bunch of comments.
I don't get to change them.
And then we'll talk about high and
low scores.
We take, as it's sort of self-evident,
that we all have bad stretches.
That we all have faults.
And that, if you can't create
an environment where you talk about them,
each of our personal growth
journeys are going to be stunted.
And so we do a lot of introspection,
a lot of reflection, a lot of discussion.
And in the second part of every
executive's review is, for
example when I'm reviewing others, the
first part is the most important message,
the second part is to go
through each core value and
talk about how other people's experience,
you with respect to integrity.
How do they experience
you with respect to fun?
How do they experience you with
respect to service excellence?
Real words, and so, and
that I get the same back.
So I think we help me and
we help each other grow as human beings,
and so I think we're reasonable on that.
>> So where most of the first years been
taking your course here which we call
Leadership Labs.
One of the things we talk to them about
in the labs is being active learners and
being active learners their whole lives,
their whole careers.
They constantly learn from what went well,
what didn't go well.
Become a better manager, leader.
You've spoken about some of
the ways you're getting feedback.
But what are some of the other
ways that you personally
have worked on your own leadership and
management skill over time?
>> Well, so, one of our pitter patters
is management is a business skill.
It's really important.
So you should study it and
think rigorously about it.
Leadership is a human thing,
not a business thing.
And if you want to get
better at leadership,
learn more about humans
starting with yourself.
And so virtually every University class
has elements of introspection and
self reflection.
And in particular,
if you have as many behavioral
deficiencies as I have you would
try to make sure not just through the 360
process but through using other tools and
outside coaches that you're continuously
forced to reflect on your self.
And that combined with having to discuss
yourself publicly is a tremendous spurt,
thing that can spur your growth, for
me to work on some of my behavioral
things, I have done things like
give myself a score everyday.
So when I took this job 16 years ago I was
43, when you still have serious behavioral
issues, which many of you'll have, you
know, doesn't mean you're a bad person.
And overall, I've got some good scores.
But I had things I had to work on.
When you're 43 and
you've been a CEO already for eight years.
That means there is some stuff going on,
I mean you're not just going to get their
feedback and then suddenly the next day,
stop entirely.
And so for some of those things, I use the
metaphor that my brother is an alcoholic.
He is now 11 years sober.
And he talks about the early years,
he said I had to win that battle
against alcoholism every day.
And so for
some of my behavioral deficiencies,
like getting angry with people.
I started giving myself a daily score and
tracked it on a spreadsheet.
Because I had to build the muscle memory
to catch myself first after I did it,
and then I could go apologize
if I had the courage,
and then catch myself
while I was doing it.
And then catch myself right
before I was going to do it.
And then after about two years
I was doing it a lot less.
But if I had not kept a daily score to
confront my reality while it was still
fresh, then I couldn't then just sort of
consistently dismiss it as a bad day.
Or the person has been bugging me for
a while, and
all the rationalizations get stripped
away when you score yourself everyday.
Did you have a drink or not?
Did you have too many drinks or not?
It just is the reality.
It is you.
It's not the external world.
>> Fascinating.
I want to go back a little
bit in your career.
Because I think it's of
interest to the student bodies.
They're thinking about where to go,
where to go next from the GSB.
You did spend a good spell at Baine.
There's a lot you learn
in a gig like that.
And I'm wondering about the transition
from that to being CEO
of an operating company.
What did you learn at
Baine that was helpful?
Are there some things you learned
at Baine that you had to unlearn?
You can talk a little bit
about the transition?
>> First of all I have two idea about
where you should go after business school.
I have one, but we'll come back to that.
On the Baine versus operating company
thing, back when I graduated,
which was a long time ago,
there, in that decade,
in my mind there weren't really
a lot of operating companies that
have thoughtful programs for
growing general managers and leaders.
And that's what we're about.
And that's what I wanted to become.
I knew that my dream was to become
a competent general manager and
leader of people.
I knew that's what I wanted
to become proficient at.
And I did not see stuff, there were jobs
out there but they weren't about that.
They were just about
learning the business and
then in consulting more generally,
in my, the way I would
advise young people is if you want to be a
general manager, leader in the long term,
that, and you find you're the sort
of person who's super bright.
You figure out the case
faster than other people.
You can be right verbally adroit
connected to your brain but
you're not a natural team leader.
You're not a natural team builder.
You're not natural in establishing trust.
Well, you got to stare at that very
realistically because if you want to be
general management leader and
you have that mix relative to the world,
there's no good or bad in this,
and you go to consulting or
investment banking,
you're existing muscles get way,
way stronger and your pay goes up,
and these other muscles stay weak.
And then you want to make a shift and
it's a nightmare.
Because you got to take a huge cut in pay
and work on your remedial capabilities.
So, you don't do it, and I got a lot
of friends who are 59, and wealthy and
not happy, because they went too much,
they didn't have a good strategy.
Similarly, if you're great at project
management and team leadership and
the rest, which I felt for me,
that was some of my natural sport for
me, a lot to learn but
a natural sport but you need help and
more strategic discipline,
more analytical discipline.
You need to just be exposed to a lot more.
Then it goes the other way,
that going there and
getting that incredible exposure and
learning those disciplines.
And then, you transfer over to a sport
you were, sort of, born to play.
And, so I think it's very, there,
there's no generic answer.
It's very person specific and it
requires incredible intellectual honesty
about your strengths and weaknesses.
And where you want to end up.
And so, for me I needed,
I needed exposure.
I needed to run with that sort
of intellect with people for
a while to make me sharper, help me grow.
I needed to become more disciplined,
analytically.
I needed all those things,
and I got them, big time.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then went to play where I always
knew, I mean, the sport I wanted to play.
Thank you.
I don't want to,
I don't want to hog all your time.
Let's open it up for, for
questions from the audience.
>> I have the first question from twitter.
How do you distinguish company as
community from company as a family.
How does one, for instance,
fire a community member?
Yeah.
Actually, when you asked about
tough moments, firing a friend.
And in some cases, someone you literally
love is a brutal thing to have to do.
And particularly if they love the village,
and you have that personal relationship.
And then you tell them they have to go.
And we used community,
which if course is made up of families,
very explicitly because the family thing,
while that level of intimacy exists
in some of neighborhoods and
some of our smaller teams, for us,
some of my senior executive team,
we love each other as we love our oldest,
dearest friends.
And we talk about it.
And so we are almost like families.
But for the bigger community,
that would be an overly aggressive word.
It would just be inaccurate to
say the entire 65,000 people
across 12 countries is a family.
It's just this,
it would be an inappropriate metaphor.
The, just like a village has
families within it, that's,
that's just more accurate.
We're serious about the metaphor,
if you're going to, it's going to,
if it's going to help you make decisions
and help you talk about decisions, and
help people understand how you want
to behave, It's gotta be real,
it's gotta make sense, it's gotta be
internally holistically consistent.
And so, the one's there, we,
I'm much better at this,
I used to be bad at giving
people bad reviews and
bad at terminating because I was
too intent on proving I was right.
I'm right about the ways you underperform.
I'm right about it's the right
decision to terminate you.
And then one of my executives who work for
me,
a guy named Tom Musselton, taught me
what I thought about conceptually but
have never applied to that area which
is the holy script of intentionality.
Until I got to the point where I
intended to be helpful to that person in
the review or in the decision, helpful, I
could never become very good at doing it.
And as I went through my year or
two of learning that from this gentleman,
there were times I cancelled the meeting
because I knew I was still going in
with my old tendency wanting
to prove I was right.
And take care and respond to any rebuttal.
And so if you go into it with the right
intention in your heart, your head will do
just fine by itself and in a village you
gotta maintain the health of the village.
Doesn't meant they're
going to be destroyed.
There are other jobs,
there are other villages.
In many cases, there are people who won't
take a demotion, and so in that case, it
becomes their own decision to go, in terms
of a majority of successful executives
have a really hard time with a demotion,
I think that's totally philosophically
inappropriate and shallow, but
it's where most human beings come from.
Shallow's not the right word, but
I think in many cases they
would have been happier.
But I think putting it
in the right context,
having the right intentionality, and
then being respectful and humane.
>> My name's Fernanda.
I would like to hear a little more about
the intentional parts of a culture so
in the beginning here you were saying
oh what we just did that was not my
intent when they started off and I'm sure
a lot of things evolved through the years.
But I would like to hear about your
vision in the very beginning and
your role as a leader in
making that vision come true.
Let me take a stab at it and then you
come back if I don't hit it right.
Intentionality is fundamental and
we just had 10 people
last night in Denver who just
went through something that I'll
describe as part of our intentionality and
that is the first word they used.
A couple of big groups that
are thinking of joining us.
And when that happens, we just invite
them to come to our big meetings.
So, a part A and a part B.
First, when I showed up, and
for reasons we can go into later perhaps,
there was a big family decision,
I did announce to the groups
like this that That number one,
I wanted to create a deferentially
healthy place for people to work and have
an unusual percentage of people say that
it was the best place they ever worked.
Not perfect, not easy, but
the best place they ever worked.
And number two is we wanted to
build the greatest dialysis company
the world had ever seen.
Then that is what I said.
And we were on the verge of bankruptcy,
we're being investigate by the SCC,
we're being sued by shareholders.
We had no COO, no CIO,
no CFO, we were in six weeks of
missing payroll of 9,000 people.
And so
when I said those words in that situation,
a lot people thought it was inappropriate
emphasis given where we were.
In my mind, if you care about that stuff,
the time to start working
at it is right now.
Either so you'd never delay.
It doesn't mean you don't have to do all
the other stuff, but there's no such thing
the leaders lead, they don't wait for
the right time to lead.
Second when I did that,
if you use this room,
a third of the people thought
it was just manipulation.
Superficial marketing, hoity toity MBA,
wants us to stay,
looks like we're going to go bankrupt.
So this is like, so if he wants us to say,
he shouldn't give us
superficial football speeches like that,
he should give us retention bonuses.
And then maybe a third of the group,
obviously you don't
know the right numbers.
Were thinking well,
that's very nice, he seems sincere,
but that'll last about a month.
And then maybe a third of the group
said wow, I would like to work in
a place that's differentially a healthy
place for human beings to work.
And has a dream of actually making
a significant impact on the world.
I'd like that, I'm hoping he's sincere and
he's competent.
And if you've not done it yet,
given a speech in a room or
two-thirds of the people,
think you're full of it, it's not fun.
But it demonstrates intentionality.
And then you say, and
by the way I know most the people in
the room think this is not pragmatic or
not sincere or naive or whatever.
And then they go okay, so
he actually knows that a bunch of us,
think it's bias and he's still saying it.
Now that's interesting.
Because at first we thought he was dumb or
naive, now we see he actually knows it and
he's still saying it.
And then people would of course say, how?
It's okay, that's what we
have to figure out together.
Here's some ideas about our
policies around the university,
here's some of our policy about
helping teammates in need.
Here's some of brainstorming here and
there on personal and
professional development and
impact on communities.
And so we started to demonstrate by
having regular meetings where the only
subject was.
How do we make this notion of being
a differentially healthy place to
work come true.
And just like if you had
a marketing problem or
a manufacturing problem
it was the agenda item.
You would generate ideas,
you would allocate resources,
you would have programs,
you would monitor the execution.
So we respected the challenge and
we demonstrated that we
were damn serious about it.
And we used to get on the phone,
as we still do it.
Every eight weeks for
a voice of the village call,
I just had one yesterday,
about 5,000 people across the world.
And in those days,
every call I'd say what is the incremental
evidence since the last call?
To suggest we're serious about
this mission and values stuff.
And so to put it way, way out there and
then at some point,
you call the question and say okay.
We call it crossing the bridge and
we have a bridge in every neighborhood.
I walk across the bridge every morning.
And after you've been with us six months,
we ask you to stand at that bridge and
decide, you never have to tell us.
And if you decide to walk across it,
it means that you've declared
that you share accountability.
For creating a differentially
healthy place to work,
having us be a community first.
And trying to have a differential
impact on health care in the world.
And so it was very explicit,
it was very much reinforced by actual
actions, actual intellectual investment.
Actual project management,
operating follow through.
Actual honest discussions
about how we were doing.
Because back then we had 9,000
people across 450 locations.
If you didn't get way intense,
it's not like being able to
call everybody in a room.
It had to be much more serious.
So I think those are some of the things
that really hammered
home the intentionality.
And got a lot people
thinking about whether or
not they wanted to cross the bridge.
And then I'll throw out one other
thing that was powerful part of it.
A bunch of managers in the first
year crossed the bridge.
They said whoa,
we believe this and we're psyched.
It would be great to retire and
say I tried to build
the greatest douse this company will
ever seen and have a differentially.
I'm on board, but when I go back to
Tulsa or New york or whatever and
talk to the 25 people in my little center.
I can't bring that alive and
were open six days a week, three shifts
a day I can't even pull my team together.
Much less convey it all and the videos
help but they're not enough and so
the village concept is
stopping at the manager level.
And so we had town halls and
their managers saying this to me and
the other senior leaders.
And we said okay,
how can we break through that?
And then somebody had
the temerity to say well,
we couldn't actually fly
all our people somewhere.
To go to meetings like we do and
discuss this stuff.
And of course,
no you can't because it's expensive and
because it's really hard to get substitute
staffing in all the local centers.
And then we said okay, but it appears
we can't do what we say we want to do.
The dream is not feasible unless we're
willing to do something that we don't have
anyone else that does.
And so ever since that time,
we have academies that are two days long.
Every teammate in America and
now or pretty soon the world is
invited to come for two days.
We have people who've never been
on a business trip, lots of them.
Some have never been on a plane,
don't have credit cards,
never checked into a hotel.
And then the vice president's right
next to the doctor who's right next to
the tech who's right
next to the secretary.
And it's two days with
no applied training.
It's all about our mission, our vision,
our language, our rituals, people go
through things like Myers-Briggs and
we have thousands of people
who've never done that.
And the second day we ask every
one to write their personal credo,
which is essentially
a statement of life purpose.
And then think about,
are they living a life consistent
with what they would say their values and
life mission is?
And then do we fit in it?
And so when we started doing that,
when we told people across America.
We will fly you for
two days of discussion and
have senior executives
there to help interact.
That was a huge piece of data for
people that we were serious.
And still all along the way,
you had to go through waves of skepticism,
cynicism, fatigue.
You set a tough budget and
does that mean it's not a village,
was that reasonably responsive?
>> I think we have time for
one more, okay?
>> Can a non citizen call you KT?
>> Yes.
>> It's a pleasure having you, KT.
>> It depends what words are in front or
after it.
>> [LAUGH] Can you speak a little
bit more about the disadvantages to
having that strong of a culture,
specifically for your leadership role?
And on a more personal note for
you and for your citizens,
how does having your daytime
job being that touchy feely?
How does that impact your life at home and
your relationship with your own family?
>> Whoa.
>> [LAUGH]
>> On the first one,
which I think was how
does the strength and
nature of the culture constitute or
it is a disadvantage?
I've not been asked that specific
question and thinking spontaneous,
I really coming up empty.
I think it's always a good thing.
Now some days it makes some stuff harder,
because you have to explain really
delicate things that are uncomfortable.
But that's sort of like the bridge
you have to pass if you want
a special culture is that's inevitable.
So I think it forces
uncomfortable human behavior.
It forces you to do stuff and
me to do stuff I might not have
the courage to do otherwise.
One of the things we tell young
leaders is get out there,
talk about your values out loud
to the people that work for you.
And it didnt take us a bunch of them
would be looking and saying [SOUND].
You think you live that value?
I'm not so persuaded and
the power of speaking out loud, so
I think it forces moments of
serious discomfort, but it's never
a A disadvantage would be my pretty strong
reaction, although I get the question.
I'm not trying to be dismissive.
And then in the second one is
particularly thought provoking considering
my son, my little munchkin is in the room.
But I believe that the DaVita village
has made me a better human being.
And I think obviously my kids have
limited memories, because they were ten
and eight when we started this adventure.
But other people who know me
throughout would talk about how it's
fostered first, encouraged,
motivated growth as a human being,
and I love most the letters we
get from people that have left.
Or when we give core value awards,
which we take very very seriously,
one of the rituals of our village.
The annual core value words.
And then they happen throughout most of
the year are very, very serious events.
There's no recognition on our night of
honor for business accomplishments.
It's all human behavior.
That often, for me the most special ones,
and often the remarks of the people who
get it will say that I've been at DaVita
six years and I'm a better daddy.
I'm a better mommy, I'm a better daughter.
That's what we're about.
For us, our culture's not a part
of our business strategy.
Our culture is about our dreams
of what life should be like.
And it just happens to be inserted
into a capitalistic enterprise.
So I feel it's, it's why I'm still,
as my son will tell you, highly imperfect.
I think it's made me way
more mindful at home.
And it's been demanding
as some of you know
back 16 years ago when I took the job,
I had just come off a private
equity backed thing.
I ran a company, it got taken over,
it was very in need financially and
really sad because we thought we
were building something special.
Then I did a private equity backed thing
with TPG and Bain Capital and it failed.
And it failed largely because of mistakes
I made, strategically and otherwise.
And I had friends who moved their
families across the country
to join this company with me.
And then a year and a half later, I had to
tell them their job was being eliminated.
And we ended up selling the piece of
the company, losing half the money, and
in the face of that, so I was working
very hard to try to save it and didn't.
And so when that was over, I told my
wife and kids that I was going to
take six months off and spend time with
them and get healthier and the rest.
And when search firms would call,
I would say, call me in six months,
I'm going to take some downtime.
I was within eight weeks of being done and
then they called for this company.
And since I had run one of their
caregiving company before that was
the most professionally fulfilling
time in my life, and so
I went through a hellatious month with my
wife, Denise, who was also an HBS grad,
was one of America's first
female venture capital partners,
about how much of my
taking this job was ego.
want to make some more money,
want to prove I can turn a company,
want to prove I can run a bigger company.
Even though it was in another city,
it was a total turn around.
My family wasn't going to move.
Versus how much of it was virtuous and
had to do with having
a positive effect on the world.
And I wasn't sure about the answer.
I knew it was a bunch of both and
clearly we decided what we did and
it was sort of pivotal in the end,
was saying, the fact that
it was going to be difficult was highly
relevant, but it's one thing to be home
five nights a week with your kids and talk
to them about leading a purposeful life,
and a whole another thing to be
there fewer nights, but lead one.
And that's the gift that The Village gave
me and so, while it's pulled me away,
and certainly there's times I've been
distracted, that I think my kids know that
I'm doing my best to lead a purposeful
life and become a mindful person.
And I think that counts for
something with them, I don't know.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We'll check that out with
a munchkin later.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All of the students who are here in
order to get into the GSB had to answer
a question which has become customary for
us to ask I guess,
which is what matters most to you and why?
>> I hate questions like that.
At DaVita people some times say, well what
matters more keeping the profits up and
the stock price up or the village?
I say it's a mirror
it's a false dichotomy,
it's like what's more
important to you air or water?
You have to have both.
To say one's more important
than the other is,
I think, a paradigm that defies reality.
And so I would say three.
One is there is nothing more special
than the people you love and love you.
And the older you get,
I'm a couple months from 60,
the more significant that he is and
what you shall sow, you shall reap.
By the time you get to my age,
a lot of stuff is locked and loaded
in terms of the depth and the breadth of
your friendships, and the texture of those
friendships and relationships with your
family, and you kids, your spouse.
Second is to try to become
more mindful each day, to tread gently
on the planet and the people in it.
This is a particularly difficult one for
me.
But there's Buddhist saying
that's strictly speaking,
there are no spiritual people,
there's only spiritual practices.
And people who act in a humane,
mindful, gentle way every day,
all day, send amazing human ripples
through the course of their life.
And so for
me that's a particular challenge and
I'm proud of the progress I've made,
because it's so important.
And then third is the more macro,
what impact do you have on the world?
And I'll tell you for people in this
room you have spectacular capabilities.
Spectacular experiences and
spectacular luck in getting to come
to a place like this with people
like you're sitting with.
And so I sincerely hope that many of you
take on the incremental responsibility
on top of the first two of trying to
have a significant impact on the world.
>> Great answer on all three points.
Do you have any closing thoughts
you'd like to share with this crowd?
>> Well, for me, honored to be here.
When I was in those seats from 1981 to 83,
it was my dream that maybe one
day I would get to come back and
talk to, excuse me,
kids like you about important topics.
So for me, getting to be here and be
here with Garth and Charles O'Reilly and
Joel Peterson, this is like a dream.
So I really encourage young people,
think about your dreams and
don't give up on them,
because sometimes they come true,
they're rarely easy, and they are rarely
linear to go after, but for me,
many of the dreams I had when I was your
age have come true, and I feel so lucky.
And the second thing I would say
is just with all the ambitions and
the pressures of two career couples and
having babies and through all that,
to really savor the adventure of life,
there's a French author, Colette,
who said I had a wonderful life,
I only wished I'd realized it sooner.
>> Please join me in thanking KT.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [MUSIC]